do you do this ranch in Pizza
abomination do you know I don't I
haven't fully developed taste palate so
I don't have need to dip my pizza into
ranch dressing today we're trying
something revolutionary I don't know
it's kind of gross it's a ranch dressing
on our pizza I used to love ranch as a
kid but I haven't had it recently same I
used to have it in middle school and I
can't remember happiness in sense it's a
thing we do with like mid grade chain
and or freezer exactly the thing you do
with yeah there's like pizza and then
there's pizza I'll repeat the schnapps
yeah I'm not one to do this because I
don't like ranch dressing but I do know
it's something that people love the only
thing Pizza I don't like is like gummy
bears and sardines have you had gummy
bear pizza no but it doesn't sound good
I could go for it come on
I love pizza this is a good example of
pizza that I would not think of doing a
range decent pizza that tastes very good
on its own I'm open line all out that
looks so gross oh it's terrific what if
I throw up I'm not that nervous this is
a pretty tame endeavor I really wanted
to like it I don't like that it's not
like a whole or disgusting
it's just like the pizza is fine on its
own it's good I feels healthy cuz it
feels like when you dip carrots into
ranch it kind of - yeah I feel like
we're eating carrot sticks but a carby
version right now I'm following
somewhere between neutral and positive
like not either it's not adding anything
or it's adding like a nice little
something that I like I just can't tell
I'm conflicted it's too much too many
flavors I hate it it's a good way to
ruin a pizza I kind of like the coolness
of the ranch on the pizza you like adds
a new layer I would argue that it's
overpowering I taste more ranch than
Pizza and I feel like that kind of
defeats the purpose of pizza I've steak
a large part of my reputation
not true no you are your face is
lighting up guys this is actually really
good I wouldn't go out of my way to get
it but if I was sitting at a table and
there was pizza and there was some ranch
I might dip a couple bites in I like
ranch so I'm into it and especially if
you have a spicy bite like this would
like cool it down honestly I think what
I'm experiencing it's a really good just
bread dipping sauce if you had to like
garlic bread some cheesy garlic bread
then you've got yourself a time that's
absolutely what it is then you got
something it's the bread in the ranch
you got pizza and ranch it's bread and
ranch and the crust is loose enough yeah
it doesn't make it better it doesn't
make it better it it makes it different
sometimes you want to try something new
so I think it was really odd you seemed
to try the ranch with pizza and for me
that just opens up the door to trying
Bora sauces with pizza yeah like hot
sauce with pizza and honey with pizza
maybe even RV sauce with pizza